[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
friday august 19th i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
if the browser is the main gateway to
the internet than the current main
gatekeepers or google and apple
together google's chrome and apple
safari account for more than 80 percent
of the web browser market
and that has regulators and rivals
raising questions about whether
anti-trust controls or greater consumer
protections are needed
joining us to discuss this is our tech
reporter miles krupa hi miles thanks for
being here thanks zoe
miles can you just lay out in a little
more detail what exactly regulators and
rivals are claiming that these two
browser operators are doing that's
anti-competitive because you know just
being big isn't necessarily
anti-competitive
that is true
the bone that people have to pick with
apple in particular
is that apple forces
other browser makers to
use what they call a browser engine that
is developed by apple
to
build browsers on apple
devices
so
google has its own browser engine
firefox has its own browser engine
however
when they want to offer a browser on
iphones they have to build them using
safari's webkit so that's the big
contention with apple
with google
we've heard from multiple competitors in
search
and other areas that
google has used
chrome to basically make it more
difficult for these competitors to
distribute their products to come across
something like duckduckgo a
privacy-focused search engine to google
you have to go to a browser and you have
to find it and google
has about two-thirds of the browser
market so
if google makes it difficult to download
something like a browser extension for
duckduckgo
then you know duckduckgo would say
that's impeding
their ability to distribute their
products
how have google and apple responded to
those claims
so the first thing to note is both
companies will say
you know this market is very
very competitive
it's easy to switch between browsers
it's easy to make a browser a default on
an operating system
you know people don't have to use chrome
they don't have to use safari
so that's their first point
and
then beyond that apple has all sorts of
reasonings for why they have this webkit
requirement
the foremost being
security that they believe it is the
most secure
browser engine and is sort of critical
to maintaining
security and privacy on apple mobile
devices other people dispute that but
that's a much longer conversation
and then
with google they maintain
that they participate in all sorts of
web standards groups and that they don't
do anything anti-competitive with the
browser extensions
and basically that chrome is one because
it's a better browser
it does seem like lawmakers though are
kind of taking note of what rivals are
saying and are looking at kind of the
the scale of the control that these
companies have over the browser market
so what kind of actions are lawmakers or
regulators around the world starting to
take
right it's still early days the uk
competition and markets authority
is doing an investigation into mobile
browsers that is really squarely focused
on apple and google
and there could be all sorts of remedies
that come out of that they could ask
that apple
stop
this requirement that other browsers use
webkit on mobile devices they could ask
google to
potentially
give options for other browsers when you
open up chrome
they could do all sorts of things to try
to promote more competition in the
market
what's the competition like now i mean
if if so many of us are using chrome and
safari you know listeners might not
really be aware of what their other
options are
yeah a lot of the alternatives are
really focused on privacy so you know
it's no secret that data is really
important to google and google collects
a lot of data on its users through
chrome
so some of the alternatives
really market themselves as privacy
friendly not collecting user data
another one i spoke to called the
browser company has made a browser
called arc
that is really trying to put a whole new
user experience on the browser
where it's basically saying
we do all of our work in the browser
these days we don't use our desktops so
the browser needs to reflect that and
things like tab overcrowding
that can be streamlined through a few
different design choices tab
overcrowding is certainly something that
i am guilty of i think there's like 30
tabs open in my browser right now
i want to take a step back for a second
how did chrome and safari become so big
and and so important to our internet
experience
yeah well safari predated chrome it was
introduced in 2003
and interestingly enough from the
beginning it had this partnership with
google where google was the default
search engine in safari so that was a
really important distribution
channel for google
and eventually google decided in 2008
that it also needed its own browser
and what that's really done for google
over time
is
it's been
really the key
portal for people
interacting with google search you know
google chrome now has
about two-thirds of internet activity
worldwide
and it's really a simple layout to the
point that they combined the url bar
where you type in websites
and the search bar where you can ask
google
questions about all sorts of things
right
so
by tying those two things together
they've really trained users
to go to chrome and to go to that search
bar
when they have a question about anything
you know this idea that a web browser
has become too big or might be giving a
big tech company an upper hand isn't
entirely new in the 1990s you know
people complain that microsoft was
giving internet explorer an unfair
competitive advantage by bundling it
with its operating system
so why are regulators kind of back at
this point now looking at browsers again
and kind of what is their impetus to to
kind of keep going and pushing this
forward
you know browsers sit at this really
interesting
intersection where
they are really important to the way we
experience the web and really important
in
determining how
all sorts of developers create
applications for the web
so i think there's a growing realization
that as more people are spending time
online
as more people are interacting with
applications that are native to the web
that these browsers are really
important not just for like these
companies as big businesses
but for this open web economy that's
sprung up over the past decade plus
all right that's our reporter miles
krupa thanks for joining us miles thanks
again zoey
and that's it for tech news briefing
this week our producer is julie chang
our supervising producer is chris
sinsley our executive producer is kateri
yoakum and i'm your host
zoe thomas
thanks for listening and have a great
weekend
[Music]
you